[Music]
foreign
laura thank you so much for joining me
on 20 minute leaders it's been years
since we saw each other
yes yes
it's been six years or seven years ago
and when i had
yeah that's up with drew bend who's now
the gsb
and we came right out of the uh right
out of the launch program
and you were so kind to join in with one
of our advisors
and and help guide us along the way over
over these over that
incredible experience is so thank you
again after all these years for your
time and i
really hope we get to collaborate again
on my next venture which will hopefully
come soon maybe withdrew
today you're running the berkeley
catalyst fund but before we get
into what that is all about which is
fascinating i'd love for you to tell me
a little bit about your background
some of the things that interest you and
how you got to where you are today
okay um so i was trained technically
you know i have a phd in chemistry so i
did my undergrad at columbia
and then i went to berkeley for my phd
and uh probably the most impactful part
of that was my advisor taking me to
taiwan
my last year graduate school and
i worked in an institute he started
there i was writing my thesis
and teaching people there about the
kinds of work we did
and it it was just a fascinating time it
was my introduction to asia
and um i loved it i just loved it
and it really uh
impacted my life after that so when i
came back
and started working in the u.s my
comfort zone was
at that interface of u.s and asian
companies so i was always collaborating
with companies in
taiwan and japan mostly at that time
what was it experienced in taiwan that
really
captured your your interest over there
you know i think it was um it was like
constant
intellectual stimulation because
everything was a challenge
you know yeah even going to the market
to buy vegetables
you know i had to learn my numbers i had
to learn some
basic words and mandarin write all this
stuff
and i would go and practice and um
you know the market at that time uh
everything was by bargaining it wasn't
like a
posted price so i would really have to
practice my
numbers and it was so much fun it was
like a sport
and um and i would go each week and the
vendors would see me improve each week
and they're very encouraging it was kind
of funny
okay so laura i want one advice for
bargaining in
asia give me one advice oh
well they taught me you know you do a
bit of back and forth and then you storm
out of the stall
and then they you turn out and then they
come and chase you
and then you go back yeah
it was it felt very strange as an
american we don't have that culture here
right
so right yeah
but um i kind of learned that was you
know a part of the culture
and to engage that way and i mean if i
just went and bought something without
bargaining the vendor was
seemed disappointed they really wanted
to engage that way
really and um yeah and as my numbers
you know as my mandarin got a little
better it was it was even more fun but
yeah wow and
so it was it was an interesting
experience
okay but one of these issues of asia
which then
formulated into more much
deeper rooted engagements over the next
few decades right
yes and so really the rest of my career
i've always been
working with companies in asia
collaborating doing
joint development um i have had
investors from there in my
startups and um yeah
it's been great and i think and
for berkeley catalyst fund we have a
number of investors
from asia as well so um i've always been
working that
interface uh between the us and and
certain parts of asia where i've been i
haven't been everywhere and each country
is different
um which i think sometimes in america we
don't appreciate
uh you know we just kind of gloss over
it
but they are different um so then what
does that happen
so tell me about the berkeley catalyst
fund because it's it's a unique
form of a fund uh that's actually in
partnership with
the university of berkeley right
so we formed the berkeley catalyst fund
actually at the request of the dean of
the college of chemistry his name is
doug clark and um
the idea was to help commercialize
things out of berkeley but also
to return some financial benefit
back to uh to berkeley and
it turns out that's kind of tricky to do
with our tax laws in the u.s because the
university is a nonprofit
institution and so uh they're not
supposed to be engaging in
for-profit activities directly like
venture capital
um so they figured out a way to do it
just to make sure that i understand the
request was how can
the university of berkeley form a
for-profit fund
that both promotes entrepreneurs and new
technologies but also
has potential returns for the university
right so they didn't form the for-profit
fund
yeah so my partners and i are not
university employees we
we sit squarely outside of the
university and so we formed the fund
um but we do have the uc berkeley
foundation
as a limited partner in the fund and the
foundation is allowed to do that
and so that's our connection and we do
return we're structured to return
some of the financial benefit back
through the foundation
so um yeah and we're not restricted to
deals from berkeley
but the return is very specific back to
berkeley and to the college of chemistry
and
fund one and um
so we have deals from berkeley from ucsf
even from stanford and one of my
partners went to stanford so we have a
lot of berkeley stanford jokes you know
it's all good fun yeah
and uh yeah we have 21 portfolio
companies now
okay and yeah it's been um
really interesting and we invest in
things that are
related topically to what's done in
college of chemistry so a lot of life
science
a lot of materials um
sustainability things like that so we're
not doing pure software
right uh in general we we are now seeing
interface of machine learning with
pharma we do look at those
kind of things or with materials
development um
but we don't we used to say we don't do
iphone games like um
the angry birds but that kind of dates
me now yeah
and is that so is that at the request
also of the of the university of
berkeley to go more of the academic
route of deeper technology deeper life
sciences and understanding how can we
solve more meaningful problems using
technology
um yes i think i think that
what i heard mostly from professors was
they wanted to see their work benefit
society and
get out there and be used yeah and so
they they kept asking can you help me
get it
out and used uh by people
and i think at berkeley the ecosystem
isn't as developed as around stanford
you know so
so it's a little bit harder for them to
do that
uh and so we're really trying to also
bolster that ecosystem and i think you
know it's it's getting better
but it's it's there's still a ways to go
um
and uh yeah but but it is
it is getting better um we do have some
professors who have
been serial entrepreneurs very
successful but not at the same
rate as stanford you know and and there
are a lot of professors who
uh have things but they're sort of
afraid to
go into being this you know a startup
founder because it's a little
daunting totally um
yeah one professor told me that years
ago when he started his startup
he literally went out and got one of the
for dummies books
because there was nobody else to help
him on campus you know
is that pretty much anywhere i turn
there's a different student group for a
different vc that
has presence on campus you know we have
these campus heroes
for practically every large vc in the
valley and they have these hidden spies
among students i was might be one of
them
that goes on and you know literally yeah
go ahead like
go into the um engineering building go
into the basement
and just start talking to some of the
phd students over there and see what
they're working on
and yeah incredible
right yeah so um
so my partner ted and i are graduates of
the college of chemistry
and because of that i think there's a
comfort with calling us
that isn't there with most vcs and so
we're often referred to as the first
safe phone call so i get phone calls
sometimes from professors saying
i think i have something but i'm not
sure i love it i've had something in
stealth mode for years
on grant money and i think it should
come out now but i'm not sure can you
just take a look and
tell me what you think and right so um
you know i think they're very guarded
about that kind of work
uh with most folks but um
yeah so we do we do enjoy early access
and special relationship we also
have that with the tech transfer
function at
berkeley um okay and so so are the terms
that or how does the fund actually
operate so
i'm assuming this is early stage
pre-seed and seed
and then how do you how do you actually
structure the deals often
right so um we did start as a
seed series a type fund and
we both lead and follow and deal so if
we're leading the deal
we're structuring the term sheet leading
the diligence
all that kind of stuff if we're
following some other
venture firm is doing that
and so we we actually like to spend
quite a bit of time getting to know the
teams
and working through uh what the plan is
and what the term sheet should be
and and we also help them assemble that
syndicate whenever
when it's a first-time entrepreneur
because they don't
really have the um connections to do
that or know how to do it really
so we're it's a lot of educational stuff
going on
in the in the process of this now one
thing that did happen that's very nice
for us that was unexpected is we
also get invited into large and
sometimes
later stage deals that normally a small
first-time
fund wouldn't see and that's because of
the connection back to berkeley
and that we're benefiting berkeley so we
have been invited into series b
we just did a series c um so that was
not expected
and you know we're a small check size
compared to the really big
uh life science vcs but that's okay
and some of them even put us in the
press release you know alongside the big
ones so
yeah you know if you look on our website
at 4d molecular therapeutics that was
the first time that happened and
it was great and we've had several of
those usually there's a
rather famous professor in those deals
um
and so yeah um
so yeah so that was that was interesting
but yeah most of our
i would say roll up the sleeves work is
with
earlier stage companies and if we do
lead the round we take a board seat so
that's a huge commitment
and when you get into venture capital
you start realizing
the fundamentally you know rate limiting
factor is your time and ability to sit
on boards
and you know so uh you can only sit on
so many before you go crazy and then
when something hits everybody at once
like covid
or years ago it was 9 11 you know
they're all needing help at the same
time wow
so so you know you don't want to be over
extended because you can't
you can't help them so you will actually
think
sometimes to join as to going to as lead
investors even though it might make
financially sense
but because you're you don't want to
stretch too thin of your time and
resource
your say perhaps we'll be a follower on
this one because we just don't have the
capacity to be
a great partner in this
that's correct and sometimes the topic
would be better served by a vc
that is more steeped in that
particular area um you know
there's some and and where we know
they're going to need more
you know more capital an example would
be like gene therapy
gene therapy is um typically expensive
to get it done and also there are firms
that are very well steeped in that
field so we would tend to follow in
those
um it depends a little bit where a
comfort
zone is you know so one of my partners
uh drew lanza who
was happily retired from morgan baylor
when we
pulled him into this his expertise is
really more
uh suited to these um machine learning
and
ai type deals so actually that's been a
huge asset now because we're seeing a
lot of those
intersect with pharma and materials
development
so um yeah so that's you know we we try
to draw in each other's
strengths we we work very much as a team
um
and we have different strengths so we we
pull that
together and how long does it usually
take for you to once you see an
interesting opportunity
uh is it is it a set around does it
revolve around the same time frame
for you to do the due diligence process
or is it dynamic
and how your and your confidence in the
company
um you know it really varies because
often we're meeting companies before
they're really ready
for our money so we're trying to coach
them
to get ready to be able to do a raise
uh and in that process we're learning a
lot about the team
but you know they haven't really pushed
go on an official raise yet
right and then later they're doing that
so
um you know it could it could be
several months before they're ready um
if we're leading
especially and trying to help them get
prepared
to raise if we're following the dynamics
of a deal vary
a lot and it depends on what's going on
with the
larger investors in the deal and what
the
you know what the momentum is there um
but yeah it um and it depends also how
hard it is to due diligence or not some
some teams are better organized and
prepared
for diligence than others um so you know
it's like how many iterations of asking
for things
and then getting the information back
you know does it take so um
yeah so there's that interesting okay so
so
where is this headed now so and you
started this a few years ago and and
where do you see both yourself and
berkeley catalyst fund let's say
three four years down the line right
so um i'm i'm hopeful we'll be raising
more funds
so we are preparing to raise a fund too
we already had some commitments
for fund um we are
we're kind of hampered by the lack of
airplane flights right now
to go visit so you know uh it's a
it's a weird time to be raising
so you know we wanted to be doing this a
bit earlier but
it just wasn't feasible with covid um
now we're we're working through it a bit
um so i see us raising growing the firm
modestly you know to to because you need
more partners
uh as well as you grow of course um yeah
and also expanding our reach i think
uh we we do see quite a bit from
stanford we'd love to spend more time
there and do more out of there
that'd be great and um we do get sent
deals from uc davis and uc santa cruz
actually one of our deals has a uc santa
cruz professor in it
um because we're unusual in the
ecosystem there's not that many
funds that serve those campuses so
exactly um
yeah and then we also see things from
alumni
you know we're not restricted to a deal
coming out of the university
so um yeah wonderful and you know we
have a very healthy deal flow that was
one of the first questions
investors asked us would you have enough
deals flowing i'm sure
and it's an overwhelming amount of deal
flow
it's yeah in fact it was overwhelming
before we had our website up
and i was a little worried about what's
going to happen when we have a website
because yeah and then everybody sees us
so
yeah um but that's a good thing you know
the more you see
the smarter you you get and it helps you
filter things out
and um some of our investors have
participated in deals with us you know
they co-invest alongside us
and the comments i get from some of them
is that our deal flow
is higher quality than what they see in
a lot of other firms and then i think in
some ways uh working closely with the
universities it
is kind of a natural filter so
um you know we're not getting the deals
that violate fundamental laws of
thermodynamics or
stuff like that which i have seen that
in other firms
so so it's nice to have
um high quality deal flow i love that no
you laura you know
you were such an inspiration to me back
then still now and and
and i know how much valve gave me
personally as a rising entrepreneur
and i'm sure that you give you give a
same if not higher value to all your
portfolio companies
so definitely i'm looking forward to
reaching out when i have my own venture
and collaborating again thank you sure
definitely yeah and before we leave i
have to ask you the last question
three words that best describe you
right um uh
i guess tenacious is one that i was
reminded of the other
day i
um i'm very relationship oriented
um and venture capital is a relationship
business
and um gosh
uh integrity is very important to me
i love that i love that i guess those
are the words i would
i would pick thank you so so much
this was wonderful thank you thank you
it's a pleasure to talk to you again
definitely see where you're going yeah
all right take care and i'll see you at
stanford when we have coffee take care
yeah looking forward to that okay bye
bye